bonjour alexis bon jeu ravi de vous
avoir dans cette matinale d'ayrté france
guillaume pelletier qui a donc annoncé
son soutien à eric zemmour un coup de
tonnerre chez les républicains pour un
coup de tonnerre pas vraiment les
républicains s'attendait à ce ralliement
certains parlent même d'un retour aux
sources puisque guillaume pelletier il
faut pas oublier il n'est jamais passé
par le rpr a même s'il dit que zemmour
représente le mieux le rpr il a commencé
au front national jeunesse il a ensuite
rejoint philippe de villiers puis l'ump
la campagne de nicolas sarkozy et le
voilà qui était alors lui se définit
comme l'épicentre de la droite donc on
voit que l'épicentre de la droite est
très à droite c'est ce que disait de lui
eric ciotti il a soutenu xavier bertrand
là devant la victoire de valérie
pécresse guillaume pelletier décide de
retourner à ses premières amours et
rejoint eric zemmour c'est logique de sa
part d'ailleurs il a voté contre le pass
vaccinale à l'assemblée nationale alors
que valérie pécresse demandé à son parti
de voter à y passer à la il n'est pas le
seul une vingtaine de députés aient
l'air ont voté contre l'avis de valérie
pécresse donc on voit bien que il est
finalement raccord avec mais même s'il a
changé un peu de partis ils restent sur
la frange très droitière de la droite et
voilà c'est pour eric zemmour une prise
de choix notamment pour les signatures
puisqu'il est en quête de signature
actuellement on va voir si ça se
concrétise en tout cas valérie pécresse
a installé son équipe et a déroulé sa
campagne annuelle du mal à faire
entendre sa voix selon vous alexis oui
j'ai l'impression que valérie pécresse
est un peu coincée alors c'est ce pass
vaccinale est un piège non seulement
pour les millions de français
qu'eux-mêmes macro emmerdes mais ils
emmerdent aussi lui pardon les
républicains et les républicains
pourquoi parce que valérie pécresse et
pour l'on voit bien que sénateurs et
députés ne sont pas forcément pour et
puis valérie pécresse elle doit se
démarquer des meules macro et c'est bien
ce que dit guillaume pelletier valérie
pécresse cml macron et elle essaye alors
il serait un crise sanitaire en tout cas
oui sur la clé sanitaires mais aussi sur
certains sujets l'europe en particulier
si vous êtes souverainiste vous vous
reconnaissez pas dans les propos de
valérie pécresse et puis elle a ce côté
un peu passé de faire une campagne à
l'ancienne elle est même allée à la cave
rechercher le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
certains ont dit que c'était une très
mauvaise idée puisque ce karcher c'est
aussi l'échec de la politique
sécuritaire de nicolas sarkozy donc le
côté
peu je serai thatcher et merkel je vais
chercher le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
c'est des vieilles recettes
les républicains ont du mal à agréger la
jeunesse c'est le contraire un pur
heures eric zemmour et on voit bien que
même si elle a installé une équipe de
campagne on y retrouve jean françois
copé par exemple enfin c'est vraiment la
vieille garde et on a l'impression de
voir la campagne fillon plus la campagne
sarkozy 2012 c'est pas très nouveau ça
donne pas très envie à des jeunes
électeurs évidemment de foncer et votez
pour valérie pécresse donc on va voir
comment ça se passe après les fortes
d'un parti qui a su sortir unis de la
primaire c'était pas évident même si la
défection de guillaume pelletier et déjà
un premier une première brique dans le
mur qui parle et marine le pen elle est
reste très mobilisé sur le post
vaccinale est peu inquiète en tout cas
des 500 voie possible pour eric zemmour
oui alors lcc ça s'envoie regza moore
peut les avoir 1 grâce notamment à un
accord avec les républicains accords
tacites un pas officielle mais elle elle
est là aussi c'est pas sa première
campagne elle sait très bien que il ya
encore du temps même si le temps se
rétrécit d'ailleurs elle disait à propos
du ralliement de guillaume pelletier à
la campagne de zemmour que zemmour
devrait brûler un cierge parce que là où
guillaume pelletier passe la campagne
très passe donc petites phrases
assassines donc elle est aujourd'hui
très mobilisés effectivement contre le
pass vaccinale mais là des troupes elle
a un parti en ordre de bataille elle est
toujours très haute dans les sondages
même après un eric zemmour qui s'est
stabilisée lui dans les sondages
une bataille à trois en tout cas à
droite eric zemmour lui est en quête de
signature on l'a dit oui
certitude ou risquent de ne pas les
avoir selon vous c'est un peu compliqué
hein comme question c'est toujours
compliqué il ya toujours ce petit
mélodrame de j'en suis presque à 500
mais pas vraiment alors en suspens
experts du suspect mobile et le trou
aussi avoir de nouveaux militants c'est
le moment ou jamais de faire parler de
soi avant que la campagne entre dans le
dur je pense qu'eric zemmour aura ses
500 signatures notamment à cause de
grâce à cet accord tacite on va dire et
aussi parce que il y a une dynamique
derrière cette candidature maintenant
que c'est officiel on a vu son mythe
depuis son meeting il a multiplié
déplacements alors il a choisi lac ce
trait au choix n'est ce qu'un avec de
villiers en vendée pour revendiquer une
france éternelle une france catholique
même contre la république d'une certaine
façon c'est une façon de faire campagne
qui va séduire une partie de l'électorat
mais qui peuvent braquer aussi d'autres
personnes qui viendraient à lui ou qui
seraient venus à lui donc à voir comment
eric zemmour va gérer cette campagne qui
va rentrer dans le temps long après le
buzz médiatique qui a été sa déclaration
de candidature mais je pense qu'il aura
évidemment ses 500 signatures et on a
l'impression que là où la gauche
s'enlise dans un débat de il faut
retirer des candidatures on n'y arrivera
pas la droite finalement va très bien
avec ses nombreux candidats qui auront
les signatures c'est ils n'ont pas ils
ont ils ont fait une primaire bien sûr
chez les républicains et là on a trois
couleurs de droite qui peuvent se
présenter aux suffrages dès le premier
tour ce qui est problématique pour la
gauche et qui ne semble pas être
problématique pour la droite on verra
cela merci beaucoup alexis pour votre
analyse ce matin c'était l'édito
politique de la matinale